rem sleep dreaming at least seems to
provide at least two different benefits
the first is creativity what we found
is that it's during dream sleep when the
brain
takes all of the information that it's
been learning and it starts to fuse it
together
in creative and innovative ways you know
it's almost like
informational alchemy and so we go to
sleep with the pieces
of the jigsaw but we wake up with the
puzzle complete
and that's one of the creative benefits
of sleep you know
and there's a reason that no one has
ever told you to stay awake on a problem
and there's a there's a very good
scientific basis
for exactly that
let's wrap up with dreams because this
will be my
fifth august off the grid and one of the
things that i've noticed
is because i try to work on exercise and
diet and sleeping better and just
general digital detox and relaxation
i've noticed in the four previous years
that i've done this that my dreams are
more vivid
during that time maybe it's from being
less distracted or
something so just broadly what the hell
is going on when we're dreaming
and and what can we do to i suppose
maybe gain more insight from our dreams
or or something to that effect
yeah and actually i have a quick
question for you so when you're doing
the detox
will your sleep schedule change where
you may start to go to bed
a little bit later and wake up a little
bit later no it'll i'll be going to bed
earlier usually because
i'm not doing as much during the day so
you know for a portion of this and
perhaps right now as this is being aired
i'm hoping that i'm on the beach
and it's a nice bright sunny day and i'm
under a umbrella and it's about 3 p.m
and i'm napping that would be nice but
then
you know after a day out on the beach by
by nine o'clock there's a good chance i
i could be sleeping
and then and then i'm still regardless
of when i go to sleep at night
i'm an early riser that definitely is
something new to me the last couple
years of my life where it's like
and maybe that's partly sunshine in l.a
you know it's sunny here usually at
about
6 or 6 30 a.m and i'm usually just kind
of ready to go at that point but i
probably will get a significant amount
more of sleep in the course of these 30
days or so
got it so firstly to stick a
pin in the daylight component um
daylight will absolutely regulate your
sleep timing
and you can use it on both ends if you
get too much light exposure in the
evening
then it will block a hormone called
melatonin
which is critical to signal to your
brain it's night time and it's time to
sleep
and so when we have too much electric
light or we're using our computers at
night
it stamps the brakes on melatonin and
that's why some people can struggle with
sleep at night so try to dim down half
of the lights in your home
in the last hour before sleep and then
you can reverse engineer the trick
in the morning get lots of daylight you
know la is a great place to do that
and it enlivens you because it now sort
of that daylight will
apply once again the breaks on melatonin
and it will help you wake up
but coming back to dreams and the
function of dreams
dreams seem to rem sleep dreaming at
least seems to provide at least two
different benefits
the first is creativity what we found
is that it's during dream sleep when the
brain takes all of the information that
it's been learning
and it starts to fuse it together in
creative and
innovative ways you know it's almost
like informational alchemy
and so we go to sleep with the pieces of
the jigsaw
but we wake up with the puzzle complete
and that's one of the creative benefits
of sleep you know
there's a reason that no one has ever
told you to stay awake on a problem
and there's a there's a very good
scientific basis
for exactly that the second interesting
thing that we've discovered and we've
done quite a lot of work in this area
is that rem sleep dreaming provides a
form of emotional first aid
and you can think of dreaming as
overnight therapy
and rem sleep dreams will take those
difficult experiences sometimes even
traumatic
experiences that you've been having and
it acts like a nocturnal soothing bomb
and it just takes the sharp edges off
those painful difficult experiences
so that you come back the next day and
they don't feel as painful anymore
and so i think in that sense dreaming
you can think of it
as well it's not time that heals or
wounds
it's time during dream sleep that
provides emotional convalescence
and those are the two functions that
we've been strongly associating with rem
sleep dreaming
what about people that don't remember
their dreams i always find it so odd
because i really do remember my dreams
every now and again i'll have a notepad
by the side of my bed and i'll scribble
something down that i want to remember
for the next morning something like that
and i do
find that there are insights and i can
piece together something that maybe i
couldn't
have otherwise what about people that
just have no memory of their dreams you
hear about that every now and again
yeah it's not infrequent it's not
necessarily pathological it's not
something that you have to worry about
or
go and see your doctor about we don't
truly understand
why there are those individual
differences
we certainly know that they are present
but we also know that those people who
say look i just don't dream
it's not really that you don't dream as
you said it's that you don't remember
your dreams because if i bring those
people into my sleep center here at uh
at university california berkeley and we
can clearly see that they're going
into dream sleep and in fact if i go
into the bedroom
well when they're in a rem sleep phase
and i wake them up and i say
can you just tell me what was going
through your mind before i woke you up
they will say it's the strangest thing i
was having a dream for the first time
it's just that when they wake up in the
morning that memory seems to evaporate
too quickly
and it doesn't seem to be committed to
conscious memory recollection
does it mean that that memory isn't
there at all
i actually don't think that that's true
i think it's quite possible that we
remember
much more of our dreaming lives than we
are consciously aware of or that we have
conscious
accessibility to but what we know from
brain science is that
implicit memory mem information that
you're not consciously aware of
can still profoundly change your
decisions and your actions
and your behaviors so it leads to a
wacky hypothesis that
in fact you know much more of our waking
life
is determined by our imprinted dream
life
but we just don't have conscious access
to that dreaming
and i say that because you know i'm sure
you've had that experience too where you
wake up and you think
i was dreaming i know what was that
dream what was that
yeah it's just gone and then two days
later you know you're getting into your
car and you see the keychain
and it instantly triggers the unlocking
of the memory of that dream
in other words that memory was always
there
it just you'd lost the ip address to go
and find it for conscious recollection
and if it's still there it could still
be changing your behavior
all right i said the dreams was the last
question but i'll give myself one bonus
question here which is
do you have one other tip or trick that
i can incorporate into this month so
that i come back
as well rested and ready to go and be
back in the
the crazy political and cultural fight
that i find myself in 11 months out of
the year
you are a brave brave man knowing what
you do and i admire it greatly i am far
too
thin-skinned uh to be doing what you do
but you're definitely a wiser man
so yeah let's not rush to judgment i
probably in the past 45 minutes just
proven that to be wrong as well but
i will give you one conventional tip and
one unconventional tip
great the first conventional tip is
regularity if i could
give you one single thing to start doing
go to bed at the same time
wake up at the same time no matter
whether it's the weekday or the weekend
and regularity is king and the reason
and because i don't think people respond
to rules that are just barked at them
they respond to the reasons not the
rules
and the reason is this that your brain
has its own 24-hour clock
and it responds best to
wrecking sort of the recognition of
regularity so when it's getting
regularity
it's going to anchor your sleep and as i
said improve the quantity and the
quality of that sleep
so aim for regularity no matter what day
it is
in terms of an unconventional tip and
this may sound a little bit strange but
if you have a bad night of sleep and
everyone has them you know i am not
immune just because i know a little bit
about sleep
i have got my big share of bad nights
and i've had my own bouts of insomnia
that i've battled and struggled with but
after a bad night of sleep
people say what should i do and my
answer is do
nothing and what i mean by that is
don't wake up any later don't drink any
more
coffee the next day don't nap during
that day
and don't go to bed any earlier than you
would otherwise
do nothing just stay the course and
repeat the same behavior
because if you wake up later then you're
not going to build up
enough of that sleep pressure that we
spoke about for you to fall asleep at
your normal time
because you slept in later and second if
you go to bed
too early because you think last night
was so bad i should get to bed early
your body is not expecting to sleep at
that different time that new
earlier time so you're just going to lie
in bed awake tossing and turning and
it's going to be even worse
and then obviously caffeine and naps
we've spoken about too so the best
unconventional advice if you've had a
bad night of sleep
is do nothing stick to your routine if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about
lifestyles instead of non-stop yelling
check out our
lifestyle playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out our full episode
playlist
they're both right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe
and click the notification bell